our uh first Speaker learned two very
important life skills during her PhD
program
how to drive a stick shift
and how to siphon gas of a hose
I'm a little worried about that one
please everyone please welcome Shirley
so today I'm going to talk to you guys
about writing and updating reports in
quarto so my name is Shirley Hahn I'm an
assistant director at the Science and
Technology policy Institute if you went
to the workshop yesterday my colleague
will Doan uh spoke there and he has
another Presentation tomorrow as well
um all right so let's just jump in
so just a quick um poll how many how
many individuals here have heard of
Porto
okay great
um well I'm not sure how helpful this
will be but for those who might be new
um I'm hoping to introduce a new tool
for you and a new way of thinking about
how to facilitate report writing or any
kind of documents
um for for your work
okay so a few things to know about Cordo
it is the next generation of our
markdown so how many individuals have
worked with our markdown before okay
that's fantastic so if you're already
working with our markdown and you
haven't switched over to Cordo this
might be the next logical best thing
um just because a lot of the features
are there to make things a little bit
more user-friendly and um and it's
pretty okay so first things first we can
create reproducible documents uh in
quarto for a variety of different
formats so including HTML PDFs word docs
and you can also do things like
presentations and books and blogs and
websites and so forth so you don't have
to use quarto just for documents you can
use it for a variety of other
presentations and formats as well
and for this particular talk I'm going
to be speaking about how we can use
Cordo for recurring documents so things
that you're going to be doing either
over and over again or on an annual
basis something where you don't want to
have to manually update
um because if you have done that before
you know it is such a huge pain I would
say
um and it's it's it's quite time
consuming all right so a few things to
introduce you uh to about Cordo if you
haven't seen it before there's actually
two interfaces so let's see if this
works can you see my I do not let's see
if I have a pointer I'm not really sure
I do okay
um so first things first is it is a DOT
qmd uh file extension so if you're
already working in our markdown or R you
can actually just change the file
extension to Dot qmd and it will
automatically convert it to a quarter
document so pretty easy things there
um and you can just do that manually
there's actually two interfaces in
quarto one on the source side which is
what's presented here you use markdown
syntax you write how you normally would
you put your inline codes there your
chunks and so forth and this probably
looks pretty standard for anybody who
has worked with markdown for those who
haven't and would like to still jump
into quarto there's a visual editor so
this is
um much more user friendly if you want
to begin and you're not quite sure how
to make things in italics or bold or put
in a header or how to insert a figure
properly using Code you can go to the
visual editor
and you can start there you can see that
there are some in the red highlighted
boxes you have formatting options for a
bold italics um hyperlinks you can
choose the heading style that you want
you can insert bullets different types
of bullets and numbers and lists and so
forth you can also look at the inserts
Tab and you have many options for tables
and figures so if you have something
that you want to go ahead and put in you
can go through here and drag and select
um your the things that you want to add
into your document or report so much
easier for people who might be new to
quarto or to markdown you can learn from
here and you can go back and forth
between the visual and the source Editor
to see what the code that portal put in
for you looks like so you can learn both
ways
okay so today I'm actually going to use
one of the evaluations that we did for
an example on how Corto can be used to
help us facilitate this report writing
so
um stippy my organization was asked to
do an evaluation of the National
Institutes of Health transformative
research award anonymized review process
so there's a lot of acronyms there
so this is a uh something that's been
happening since 2009 and they wanted to
change up the grant review process so in
the regular Grant review process the
individuals your institutions your
collaborators are all of that
information is made public to the
reviewers themselves so that they can
assess both you as a pi as well as the
proposal that you are um you're
proposing here
they decided to try and see if an
anonymized review process in which all
of those informations are withheld from
the reviewers might be a more a fair and
unbiased way to do the grant review and
hopefully lead to increases in both
applicant as well as awardee diversity
so stippy we were asked to do this
during the first year of the
implementation in FY 2021 the report is
just made public
earlier on this year we provided the
second year report just to the sponsor a
few a few weeks ago and hopefully that
will be up soon as well
um but overall it was a 200 Page report
um it was very very data heavy uh most
of the report has lots of tables and
figures um and the text is very
um very heavy so and we were contracted
to do this once a year for the first
three years so fy21 all the way through
FY 23.
all right before I kind of jump into why
we're going to use quarto aside from the
fact that it's a 200 Page report that we
have to update annually I also want to
point out that just like many other
reports right this uses multiple data
sources the review process on this right
hand figure is actually a three-phase
process where each phase has different
reviewers they're asked to assess the
application in different different parts
of the application and so what we're
going to see here is we conducted a
variety of surveys of applicants of the
administrative staff of different kinds
of reviewers for editorial board as well
as technical reviewers and ask them what
their process was for applicants if they
were able to anonymize their application
correctly for everybody else were they
able to actually review and judge the
proposal based on an anonymized
application we also have demographic
information from admin administrative
records given to us by NIH so we have
lots of data coming in
many different sources and we're trying
to provide a cohesive story with all of
this
all right so I'm going to give one one
two and a half sentence example so this
is the first uh result
um from our applicant survey and what we
see here is we have you know simple
things like a response rate we have 105
of 176 applicants that were listed as a
pi the percent of those and 22 of the
119 co-applicants completed the survey
and some additional information about
who responded and and so forth
everything that's in a red box will have
to be updated for the next year or the
year after right there's that's a lot of
things in a red box for Just Two and a
Half sentences
um and before I think most of us are
doing this manually so we run our
analyzes we run our codes and then
somebody that
gracious person on our team has the task
of you go in and you find where all of
these places are and you update all of
these numbers manually so that's not
great right it's um one it's a lot of
numbers to to update it's very easy to
make a mistake you might forget halfway
well did I update this number did I
update all of the numbers in this
sentence
um there's just a lot of chances for
error it's also very time consuming
again this was a 200 Page report you're
talking about over 50 percent of this
has to be updated every year
and it's also really difficult to
maintain internal consistency of the
document if multiple people are trying
to update different parts of the
um of the report all right so what if
there is a better way and there is so
how can you create a reproducible
updatable report
um so are you already doing some of
these which I would imagine most of most
of you guys are
um you're already doing all of your data
cleaning and wrangling in some form of
portal supported language for this uh
presentation I'm using R
um you already have your functions for
your data analyzes and you're already
creating tables and figures uh in our or
you already know how to do that and you
are already using our markdown the next
logical step might be to move on to
quarto
all right so starting a dark quarter
document if you're familiar with this
I'll Breeze through a lot a little bit
of this since most of you have already
experienced with our markdown we have
our yaml header
um we can indicate what format we want
and then we use markdown syntax here
um in this particular document I am
reading all of my functions on my data
clean data and so forth so that it is
already ready for use
um for me to call in my report writing
so we're going to use this simple
sentence as an example of how to do this
in quarto again a lot of this might look
familiar if you're already familiar with
markdown so here we have the sentence 86
of 128 applicants listed as the contact
Pi completed the survey and of these 86
combined responses uh 70 were new and 60
were repeat
so what we're going to do in R here is
we're going to read our survey data in
the survey is formatted in a way such
that each respondent is one row of data
we're going to take the number of rows
for that data frame that we have the
answer would be 86 in R and then we're
actually going to turn this into words I
was very very happy to find that there
were things already out there that was
doing this so we're going to use the
English package and the English function
to take that 86 that numeric number and
turn it into words it is actually still
a numeric number even after you use the
English function that is why we also
have to turn it into characters and then
we're going to capitalize that first one
to get 86. so lots of ways to make sure
that we can Implement all of this so
that we don't have to write anything out
or manually update
all right so not everything we are
calculating right some things we need to
hard code in because those are just the
parameters for those years so in this
instance we have a total of 128
applicants we didn't know that from the
survey that was just a number that was
given to us from the sponsors uh we're
hard coding that in as the total number
of applicants we also have to update the
years of the reports so we're in this
particular example we're using fy22 and
the previous year as referring to the FY
2021 so looking at uh the second red box
here the percent of respondents to this
survey we would do our normal
calculations in r with the number of
survey responses over the total
applicants we would get something like
0.672 right in our output and then we
would
um we can use paste and and pretty it up
for the actual report writing put in the
parentheses
simplify it to one decimal Place put in
the percentage signs and so forth
all right other simple calculations so
all of this should be pretty easy you
probably already have all of this
information as you're writing your data
analysis anyways
um now we're just kind of putting in
together linking things together so that
you can insert them into the report
where you need them to so here we have
the number of new applicants and that's
just going to be the number of survey
responses minus the number of repeat
applicants where repeat applicants was a
subset of individuals who answered a
particular way for a survey question and
then the number of repeat applicants is
just the number of rows there
all right so what does this look like in
actual Cordo
um so first we can put in the headers so
things match the way that we want them
to to for results
um a sub header for response rate and
you can see that these are we have the
inline R codes that are the exact same
as what I had presented in the previous
slides but uh this will generate exactly
this um these two sentences so it looks
like quite a lot of
if you're looking at the Portal Part
itself but I think most of us already
have a lot of this coded into our data
analysis right it's just putting it into
inline
um codes so that it is next to the words
that you already have or that you want
to use
all right a few other special things to
point out again some of these already
exist in our markdown quarto makes it
slightly easier because it also now
allows for cross-referencing
um so adding footnotes so in this
particular instance we have referencing
a webinar that NIH hosted to answer
questions from applicants and we want to
put in a footnote where that webinar is
available for hyperlink so using uh
using the format of
of how to put in a footnote there uh
also to put in figure captions so down
at the bottom we see we have our figure
caption the location of the figure
itself in a in a folder I called images
and then the last little bit there
um that entire thing in curly brackets
um the hashtag figure for noting that it
is actually a figure and the last little
bit web program officer what we have
there is the ID tag for that particular
figure so that you can reference it in
your report anytime that you need to
which is what you see up here
um when you say at fig again referencing
that you're talking about a figure that
you just created and which figure you're
talking about and the nice thing to know
about this is notice that your figure
actually comes after you're
cross-referencing so it doesn't have to
occur in a yeah it doesn't have to occur
before when you actually cross-reference
it in a report
all right so this is what it looks like
we have our footnote automatically show
up there it will automatically number
itself in a sequential order so you
don't have to worry about that same with
your figures as well as tables it will
sequentially order itself and then we
can also see that the cross reference
shows up and it's also hyperlinked so
that it can automatically take you to
the figure or table that you're
referring to and lastly for footnotes
even though it's not shown on this slide
it will show up at whatever format that
you're working with so at the end of an
HTML page or the bottom of a word or PDF
page so it is already formatted for all
of those
okay and so um that was a lot but I
think a lot of it probably already looks
familiar
um so when does writing a report in
quarto make sense
um I have an example here of the NSF
science and engineering uh indicators
reports you can see here that it's a
it's a bi-annual report every two years
something like this would be the perfect
example of when you want to use
something like Porto to reproduce your
documents right you are working with
data that are pretty much the same your
data structures are getting read the
same way it's the same type of data that
you're working with it's just being
updated
um your report is not that one-time
report again this example here is a
four-time report since 2012.
and you find yourself using a lot of the
same checks that you've already used in
your previous documents if you're
copying and pasting a lot there's a
better way to do things
um so if you if you're finding yourself
going in and manually updating things
like tables and figures
um and those types of things it might be
better to put The Upfront time uh in the
beginning and go ahead and take the
codes that you've already written and
put it into quarto so that all you have
to do at the end is Click render and
then you have your document out in front
of you and the other time that you might
be interested in using this is not only
if you have a complete document that
you're ready to to make or create but
let's say you are working with data that
are being collected and your deadline
unfortunately is super super close to
when your data is being done collected
and you want to have some semblance of a
report by that time so as your data is
still being collected or finalized you
can go ahead and do some of these things
right you know probably the type of text
that you want to put in and you know
where that information is going to come
from you can go ahead and create a
document and and run whatever data that
you have so that when you have your
final clean data you can go ahead and
hit that render and have a pretty much
finalized document or report at the tip
of your hands
okay and with that I think I will stop
um thank you so much if you have any
questions please feel free to find me or
email me at my email address and I hope
this helps you think about whether
you're able to do anything in quarto to
facilitate your workload thank you